hey I've been tailing Pento and I think
you were right there's something weird
going on with that guy I knew it oh
can't believe I'm going to sleep with
him well you don't have to no I'm going
to something's not right about that guy
why just because he keeps threatening to
kill me in the middle of a police
precinct uh grow up because I'm
physically attracted to him and that's
bad I'm only attracted to creeps the
vulture the Sham well guy when I was a
kid I had a major crush on the evil
gremlin stripe are you crazy yeah well
I'm not going to Bone Gizmo I what
careful with momento
it's going to be
fine
Diaz
Pento what's up what's up with you I
need you to sign this report okay I'll
sign your
report
what the
hell careful the Ink's still wet maybe
this will
help okay they got to knock that off
locen up sard some love baby it's March
man shut up guess who got their dealer
nice had to go down we chased him
through a Subway tunnel back up through
a storm drain adri and I got engaged and
then we busted him with half a kilo of
Coke in his sock wait wait wait wait
what did you just say it was in his sock
these dummies they never think we're
going to check their socks no before
that weirdo the getting engaged part oh
yeah we got engaged engaged engaged yeah
as in to be wed yeah seriously yeah yeah
amazing we want Deets tell us everything
I don't want to toot my own horn or
anything but it was
super
romantic you follow I'll cut him off in
the alley okay wait you want to get
married yep I love Adrien every time I
see him my heart just explodes wow
that's like some lion old Richie grade
Love Stuff hey figas my fiance Adrian
pimento said when I caught you I should
read you this
letter I want to lick the skin off your
body baby oh that sdes for me I want to
rip the skin off your body
jimmmy
you punching
holes yeah that's way too much paper not
for
me can even get a cup of
coffee well I'm have to find some yellow
paper so I can do this all over
again all right Diaz that's it what's
going on with you two oh you noticed it
yeah I noticed it everyone's noticed it
a convicted pervert ask me if you guys
could cool it I don't know what to tell
you something between us
Serge something dark and Urgent Jake I
need you to tell Rosa that I love her
okay do that for me also tell her
this oh oh
my
ew that is very graphic
Adrien got it I don't think I can say
any of that to
Rosa I could have done that yeah I know
you could have but you didn't I
did I mean there are lots of other poles
guys a whole street full of them so
Adrien when we going to stop messing
around and do this thing
uh never what you know what I just
realized I I forgot something at home
I'm just going
to that was weird you okay
yes pto's going to come back we're going
to get married and we're going to have
sex on F is grave just like we planned
do they find figas not yet but they're
confident they will and when they do
detective Pento can come home can't wait
I'm going to eat his face off you guys
are so cute Pento you son of a
you're the son of a oh we'll see
who's the son of a oh yes we
will a so
sweet violent yeah this is awkward I'm
sure they'll stop
soon and it's escalating let's go left
my phone in a briefing room it's been 20
minutes you think they're still they're
not doing anything kissing just turned
to talk it's like why you at work here
listen up we have an announcement to
make when I was in that usbeck prison
choking on my own blood because my face
was being beaten in I realized life is
funny that's what you realized and it's
short we're picking up where we left off
when ader and went into hiding we're
getting married tomorrow oh tomorrow
that's real quick thank you Serge and we
want it to be beautiful and Lush and
romantic
just like a Nancy Myers movie She's our
favorite director a I love you've got M
that's Nora Efron you idiot I know oh my
God Adrian I'm so sorry you must be so
mad at me what of course I'm not mad at
you are you kidding jealousy is like the
hottest emotion that's do this okay
let's do
it you excited for being married yeah I
love Rosa I can't wait to just Jam my
tongue in her ear holes and eat the hair
off her head I'm giddy oh that's cute
you wanted me to tell you that that he
loves you is that it did he say anything
else uh may the Lord be with
you Adrien oh than
God who you scared me I thought you left
I did I was burning my fingerprints off
in a gas station bathroom when I thought
about what Jake said I couldn't leave
without seeing you one last
time I want to lick your whole body
clean like a kitty cat yeah I'm going to
give you two a little
space I have to go but I'll be back for
you I'll wait and while I'm waiting I
will find that FBI agent and I will rip
his head off with my bare hands that is
the sweetest thing anybody's ever said
to me I love you I love
you all right we have an announcement to
make we're not getting married a you can
shove those saws up your butts yeah or
I'll come out there and I'll do it for
you what an interesting event I just
feel like we're rushing things we love
each other but we haven't even really
spent that much time together we've
never even been on a real date so we're
going to start
there shut up thank you for the presents
we're keeping them all of them yeah if
you got a problem with it come talk to
us in the parking lot then she wants us
to type up an email these letters to
pimento in Argentina are they sexual in
nature crazy sexual are we able to send
that email to Adrian oh yes he wrote
back right away it wasn't as graphic as
I feared he wrote the number eight equal
sign equal sign equal sign equal sign
equal sign equal sign equal sign capital
D oh I see what this is this is a yep
hey babe you forgot your lunch at home a
thanks Adrian sweetest of course I
french kissed every slice of meat in
that sandwich I your Boogie wait say
goodbye to Mommy ooh don't mind to fight
do all right I'm going to just look over
here doing
that hang on were you creeps watching
that the whole time I'm just kidding I
know you were it's like an eclipse you
should always look at it with both eyes
wide open full on you're welcome I love
you babe love you too yeah
Diaz can we talk what do you want Pento
listen sge gave me some really great
advice
so Rosa Diaz will you marry me what this
is what you told me to do I barely said
anything you cut me off way too early
starge stay out of this gladly no I will
not marry you how about we just get a
drink
first yeah yeah that sounds nice oh
that's actually
sweet nope so is this a sexy stab in the
face or an angry stab in the face
the hell un Stu yeah I rigged it that's
what you get for being a nerd who wear
sequ belts cool people die gruesome
preventable deaths oh here's my
ride pto's here hi Pento Amy it has been
too long when are you going to let me
meet my godson he's not your godson okay
but when you die I am going to raise him
all right let's go yeah I got to drop
you off and then I have a plane to catch
what where are you going uh I took this
job protecting a diamond mine in
Northern Canada that's being terrorized
by a pack of woles apparently it's
illegal to shoot them so I have to tear
them apart limb from limb how long are
you going for as long as it takes me to
find the alpha kill it take control of
the pack and then completely decimate
The Diamond
Mine total double cross all right let's
ride Bye by Amy hey can to talk to you I
have a question is it will I ever
forgive you for betraying me and
abandoning me in a car no I have no
questions about that interaction it was
funny and I'm pleased with how it played
out this isn't about the heist what did
you think about um me and Pento to us a
couple oh uh I don't know you guys
always made me a little uncomfortable
weren't a lot of boundaries is this
about that time we smashed in your car
you did which car all of them and once
in your dad's
Miata